im april 2000 21 erhalten die grünen die
bislang größte parteispende in ihrer
geschichte ein unterstützer spendet eine
million euro das geld hatte er nach
erfolgreichen bitcoin spekulationen
übrig die grünen machen die parteispende
öffentlich noch am selben tag
verschwindet ein artikel von der website
des grünen europaabgeordnete sven
giegold der hatte sich kritisch mit
digital währungen wie bitcoin
auseinandergesetzt stattdessen findet
sich auf twitter ein anonymer beitrag
der giegold unterstellt plötzlich nichts
mehr gegen bitcoin zu haben
wie sich herausstellt wurde die website
des grünen europaabgeordneten gehackt es
entsteht der eindruck die grünen seien
käuflich
ein angriff auf die website eines
politikers mit dem ziel eine ganze
partei zu diskreditieren
die grünen bemerken den angriff schnell
und wehren sich in den sozialen
netzwerken
second league nennen experten diese neue
methode bei der die opfer erst gehackt
und dann mit zum teil gefälschten
informationen in verruf gebracht werden
im vorfeld der bundestagswahl würde für
politiker und parteien die gefahr
steigen mit dieser und anderen methoden
angegriffen zu werden warnen die
behörden der bundesinnenminister gab
mitte juli extra eine pressekonferenz es
geht um den schutz der bundestagswahl
vor manipulationen die illegitime
einflussnahme durch akteure aus dem in
und ausland
dazu zählen unzulässige aktivitäten im
cyberraum
weekend league oder hecken publish
operation seit februar diesen jahres
beobachtet das bfv intensiver angriffs
aktivitäten eines akteurs in deutschland
nach bisheriger erkenntnis lage ist ein
nachrichtendienst nicht hintergrund
wahrscheinlich
im fokus dieser phishing angriffe der
cyber gruppierung ghostwriter stehen
insbesondere private e mail adressen von
abgeordneten des deutschen bundestages
und der landtage und deren mitarbeiter
zuständig für die abwehr digitale
angriffe das bundesamt für sicherheit in
der informationstechnik deutschland ist
das größte einflussreichste
wirtschaftlich stärkste land im zentrum
von europa und natürlich ist es so dass
andere akteure vielleicht versuchen die
auch die politik mit zu beeinflussen wer
sind denn vor allem ziele solcher
hacking angriffe gab es einst gefragt
die parteien selber vergab es vielleicht
eine brechung bei digital parteitagen
und anderen themen wo es schwierigkeiten
gegeben
da gibt es aber natürlich auch den
einzelnen kandidaten
die kandidatin die vielleicht ein katzen
foto auf facebook postet für die katzen
mit gewalt etwas was sie aber gar nicht
gewesen ist einander zur über das
account gehabt hat lassen zu themen die
zu erwarten sind setzten hirnlos und
darum sensibilisieren wir sehr stark
über die parteien und da machen wir
deutlich mehr als bei der bundestagswahl
[Musik]
ich treffe till eckert seit fast drei
jahren und checkt er fakten für
korrektiv
das gemeinnützige recherche zentrum hat
sich zur aufgabe gemacht falsch
nachrichten im netz aufzuspüren und zu
widerlegen auch er beobachtet vermehrt
aktivitäten im netz und eine zunahme von
des informationen im zusammenhang mit
wahlen vor allem prominente politiker
und regierungsmitglieder seien immer
wieder ziel von verleumdungskampagnen
und falschen behauptungen
sie ist ein foto von heiko maas und da
sagt er dann überfordert eine
impfpflicht für lebensmittel käufe wir
hatten da recherchiert und
herausgefunden dass das frei erfunden
das zitat ist wie habt ihr das
herausgefunden zum einen mal ganz
klassische journalistische nachfrage
natürlich im auswärtigen amt du gehst
über eine suche in google news archiv
vor du kannst in der datenbank faktor
das ist ein zitat daten beim kanzler
gucken es gibt genios dieses eine
pressedatenbank und haben aber auf
diesen ganzen zeit natürlich nichts
gesehen wie viele menschen erreicht es
dann ungefähr
wir gehen davon aus dass wenn etwas
tausend mal geteilt wurde auf facebook
erreicht dass potenzielle millionen
menschen falsch nachrichten kursieren
vor allem in sozialen netzwerken und
messenger diensten wie telegramm dort
können tausende beiträge lange unbemerkt
kursieren weil sie vor allem unter
freunden und bekannten geteilt werden
halten die nutzer die nachrichten oft
für war
facebook spielte besonders bei der us
wahl 2016 eine entscheidende rolle dem
unternehmen wurde vorgeworfen nichts
gegen des informationskampagnen auf
seiner plattform getan zu haben vor
allem die präsidentschaftskandidatin der
demokraten hillary clinton wurde opfer
von zum teil kruden
verschwörungstheorien
so soll sie angeblich teil eines
kinderschänder rings gewesen sein der
menschenhandel über pizza lieferdienste
in washington organisiert haben soll um
die verbreitung falscher behauptungen in
deutschland einzudämmen kooperiert
facebook seit zwei jahren mit recherche
netzwerken die korrektiv um falsche
nachrichten zu kennzeichnen und dann
siehst du hier quasi das pulver
ausgegraut und den kassier den grund
anzeigen und sie ist dann hier fakten
prüfung durch korrektiv desinformationen
werden also mit einem warnhinweis
versehen gelöscht werden sie aber nur
wenn der post gegen deutsche gesetze
oder die gemeinschafts richtlinien von
facebook verstößt
oft summieren sich falsche informationen
zu umdeutungen und erzählungen so
genannten negativen
michael gerade in zusammenhang mit
wahlen das nati von betrug ja das ist so
negativ dass existiert schon ziemlich
lange wie gesagt und wir hatten jetzt
sachsen anhalt hier haben wir zum
beispiel den herrn weiner fühle mich von
der partei die basis
die basis ist eine neu gegründete partei
die aus den demonstrationen gegen die
korona maßnahmen hervorging für mich ist
bundestagskandidat der partei er
verbreitet auf dem youtube-channel
liberty news berlin falsche behauptungen
zum ablauf der wahl vom sechsten juni
2021 in sachsen anhalt
die muss man sich angucken wir gehen
davon aus dass briefwahlstimmen sind und
wir gehen davon aus dass in großem
umfange getürkt worden ist und das sagte
hier einfach so eine kamera kleines ding
100.000 aufrufe das ist eine partei die
jetzt antritt mehrere falschaussagen mit
dabei
insofern ist das was der mann da von
sich gibt so einfach nicht richtig
während der wahl am 6 juni sind
aufgetaucht hat eine person
geschrieben sie sei als wahlhelfer dort
tätig gewesen und das ganze team sei
bereit stimmen für die afg zu entwerten
zu diesem post eines anonym nutzers gibt
es ein foto das die angeblich korrupten
wahlhelfer zeigen soll das foto aber ist
ein standbild aus einem video das die
stimmauszählung in nevada bei der
us-wahl 2020 zeigt trotz der billigen
fälschung verfängt die meldung
es gab dann den hashtag wahlbetrug auf
twitter der dadurch entstanden das heißt
das ding war durchaus erfolgreich der
vorwurf dass wahlen in westlichen
demokratien gefälscht sein taucht vor
allem in sozialen medien häufig auf aber
auch der russische staat sender rtk das
immer wieder zum thema seit 2014
berichtet ein online ableger des senders
als rt de auch auf deutsch das programm
richtet sich vor allem an eine rechte
alternativ öffentlichkeit für viele
nutzer ein erster schritt in die welt
der desinformationen
das rt deutsche ganze unterseite hat
wahlmanipulation nennt da geht es um den
offenen brief von pensionierten us
generälen die geschrieben haben die wahl
2020 seien manipuliert worden das ist
überhaupt gar keine hinweise oder belege
dafür gab das lässt rtl hier galant aus
oder in unseren augen ist eine kontext
auslassung in so einem fall oder auch
etwas was man einen falschen kontext
statt genauso schlimm wie eine
industriell flüge oder
falschbehauptungen die kanäle sind alle
offen und sind alle da und ich glaube
dadurch entsteht gerade die große gefahr
auch jetzt vor der bundestagswahl
laut eigendarstellung hat rtt das zitat
ziel eine gegenöffentlichkeit
herzustellen für kritiker ist es ein
russischer propagandasender mit dem ziel
die westlichen demokratien zu schwächen
ich hätte gern mit rt de über deren
rolle bei der berichterstattung über die
bundestagswahlen gesprochen und über den
einfluss der russischen regierung auf
rtl.de ein interview hat der sender
kurzfristig abgesagt meine fragen
beantwortet rt de schriftlich wir
begleiten die bundestagswahl wie jede
andere redaktion in deutschland wir sind
an medienunternehmen das sich mit
berichterstattung befasst nicht jedoch
mit politischen kampagnen wir können
nicht für die russische regierung
sprechen
verunsicherung zweifel und am ende ein
verzerrtes bild der realität das ist das
ziel der beeinflussung der gesellschaft
wieso eine verunsicherung kampagne
funktioniert erfuhr mirko drotschmann
bekannt ist der youtuber als mister
wissen to go er hat mehr als 1,5
millionen abonnenten
ich bin journalist ganz klassische
unterwegs im fernsehen aber vor allen
dingen auch im internet im mai bekam er
von einer pr-agentur eine anfrage für
geld eine nachricht auf seinen kanälen
zu verbreiten ja das war hier wieder
diesem 18 mai mit ihrem google 19
wir würden sich einladen diesen link zu
teilen da ist also relativ harmlos
formuliert gerade einen artikel der
mitten im satz abgebrochen war und
statistik die völlig aus dem
zusammenhang gerissen wurde und
angeblich zeigen sollte dass bei impfung
mit biontech weise besonders viele leute
gestorben sind haben die dir sonst noch
irgendwelche vorgaben gemacht wie der
inhalt dann irgendwie aufbereitet das
erste was hier steht ist direkt ein
eine illegale sache ja hier benutzen
nicht die wörter werbung oder
gesponsorte das video in deinen post sie
sollen aussehen die einen ratschlag an
dein publikum und das ist in deutschland
verboten du musst kennzeichnen wenn du
werbung macht presst ihre das material
als deinen eigenen unabhängigen blick
und das finde ich schon kapiert also
dass man dazu auffordert die leute
anzugeben also irgendwie versucht
herauszufinden wer das ist ja wie
herkunft das war das erste was ich
gemacht habe als teenager habe ich mir
dann guckt was ist das denn für eine
agentur wir nach deren website gegangen
hab gesehen ob edel sitzen in london
dann habe ich aber gesehen der chef lebt
in moskau habe dann noch eine verbindung
gefunden von dieser agentur zu einer
großen russischen
ein manipulationsversuch aus dem ausland
drotschmann hat ihn schnell durchschaut
in brasilien und indien waren die
hintermänner erfolgreicher dort
veröffentlichten influenza mit zum teil
millionen verloren diese
falschinformation über den impfstoff auf
ihrem youtube kanälen
die pr-agentur anscheinend eine
briefkastenfirma in london die spuren
führen nach russland wer könnte dahinter
stecken ich stoße auf eine neue
strategie den westen zu beeinflussen der
verdacht russische unternehmen werden
vom staat eingespannt um politische
ziele zu verfolgen
ich treffe alexej stettin er war
geschäftsführer des internetproviders
elcom und lebt mittlerweile in
deutschland in russland läuft gegen ihn
ein strafverfahren wegen betrugs ein
auslieferungsgesuch der russischen
regierung hat die bundesregierung im
oktober 2020 abgelehnt mit dem hinweis
dass es sich um ein politisches
verfahren handle
der russische geheimdienst war
irgendwann aufstieg ihn zugekommen
war mir war es quasi eine inoffizielle
bitte aber es war fast unmöglich sie
abzulehnen wenn man eine solche bitte
ablehnt ist man nicht mehr eingestellt
russische geheimdienste hätten ein
system entwickelt um weltweit
internetkommunikation auszuspionieren
dazu würden russische it-unternehmer wie
stettin gezwungen server in
verschiedenen datenzentren privat
anzumieten mit den zugängen können
geheimdienste alle umliegenden server im
datenzentrum unbemerkt auslesen stiens
firma diente als tarnung für die
spionage im netz
man selbst zahlt nur noch die miete für
den server die kontrolle darüber erhält
sofort der fsb ich muss sagen dass der
it sektor im allgemeinen sehr stark von
geheimdienstlern infiltriert ist eine
große zahl der mitarbeiter müssen mit
verbindungsoffizieren kooperieren es
gibt eine ganze reihe von aufpassern
seitens des fsb und anderer
geheimdienste
was alexej stettin mir erzählt klingt
unglaublich russische unternehmen sollen
von geheimdiensten benutzt worden sein
um hacking operationen zu koordinieren
zum beispiel auf den bundestag
an diesem system sind fast alle
großunternehmen beteiligt die größten
sozialen netzwerke die größten mail
services die in russland tätig sind
suchmaschinen und banken ganz zu
schweigen von den unternehmen die
antiviren software verkaufen und
digitale sicherheitssysteme anbieten
alle von ihnen sind von fsb offizieren
infiltriert
es ist sehr schwer die informationen von
alexei ski team zu überprüfen große
russische internetfirmen bestreiten
öffentlich mit geheimdiensten zusammen
zu arbeiten
laut alexej stettin erbeuten die
digitalen angreifer daten wie e mail
inhalte zugänge zu social media accounts
und vieles mehr
dann kommt der einsatz von kräften die
wir troll fabriken nennen ganze gruppen
die in sozialen netzwerken arbeiten die
diese informationen schließlich
verwenden ich denke wenn wir über einen
ausgewachsenen informationskrieg
sprechen ist er jetzt in vollem gang
an des informationskampagnen sind
zehntausende fake-accounts beteiligt zum
teil computergesteuert sie tragen die
falschen nachrichten in die sozialen
netzwerke facebook geht mittlerweile
dagegen vor von den 150 kampagnen die
wir entfernt haben kommen 27 aus
russland durch beispielsweise die
internet research agency insofern ist
russland natürlich global der größte
akteur in diesem bereich es gibt aber
auch andere länder und staaten wie
beispielsweise den iran china und viele
andere die diese tools und diese
taktiken anwenden
und die wir entfernt haben über die
vergangenen jahre wenn diese fake
accounts jetzt immer wieder gelöscht
werden was es denn dann die neue taktik
der akteure um dann irgendwie doch
weiter einfluss haben zu können also
sprechen darüber hecken liegt kampagnen
das heißt akteure versuchen sich
beispielsweise in die social media oder
eben auch die e mail accounts von
kandidaten zu hacken um diese kandidaten
zu diffamieren hecking ist kein neues
phänomen aber der umgang mit den
erbeuteten daten stellt eine neue
bedrohung dar mit einem leak der
weitergabe von vertraulichen
informationen können einzelne
bundestagskandidaten aber auch ihre
gesamte partei angegriffen werden
bereits 2015 gab es einen groß
angelegten hacking angriff auf den
bundestag die russische hacker gruppe
atp 28 alias fans iber verschickte
phishing mails an abgeordnete ein link
in dieser mail installierte ein
schadprogramm um den angriff zu stoppen
musste das komplette computernetzwerk
des bundestages abgeschaltet werden im
märz 2021 gab es einen erneuten
russischen angriff auf bundestags und
landtagsabgeordnete
manuel höferlin von der fdp ist
vorsitzender des digital ausschusses im
bundestag
dessen mitglieder registrieren
permanente hecking versuche auf
abgeordnete sind sie selbst auch schon
mal angegriffen worden ich werde
andauernd angegriffen da ich nicht drauf
klicken und auch keine daten irgendwo
ein geber- und auch sehr viel
verschlüsselt kommunizieren
glaube ich dass das bisher noch nicht
erfolgreich war man muss allerdings
ehrlicherweise sage nein richtig
erfolgreicher angriff ist halt auch der
der nicht bemerkt wird zuständig für die
abwehr der digitalen angriffe ist das
bundesamt für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik bsi
das bsi ist auch auf die parteien
zugegangen um kandidierenden insgesamt
die möglichkeit zu geben ihre eigenen
accounts abzusichern ich befürchte aber
leider dass viele dieser angebote auch
nicht wahrnehmen und das doch etwas
nachlässig behandeln wie sie selbst mit
ihrer eigenen sicherheit umgehen und die
sind diejenigen die wahrscheinlich am
ende auch erfolgreich angegriffen werden
können
die it-systeme angreifbar
drohende manipulationen durch des
informationen und dann ist da noch der
eigentliche ablauf der wahl
darüber wacht georg thiel er ist
bundeswahlleiter und verantwortlich für
die durchführung der bundestagswahl
also wir spielen verschiedene szenarien
durch und versuchen mit den befreundeten
behörden das sind vom bundeskriminalamt
über verfassungsschutz bsi unser
zentraler it dienstleister das sind
netzbetreiber die wir haben das sind
aber auch andere vereine die uns
behilflich sind bei der einen oder
anderen sache versuchen wir ein sehr
enges netzwerk zu spinnen um gefahren
abzuwehren
am sicheren ablauf der bundestagswahl
sind mehr als 500.000 helferinnen und
helfer beteiligt waren sind das
herzstück einer demokratie wird das
vertrauen in sie erschüttert leidet die
glaubwürdigkeit des gesamten politischen
systems für angreifer ein lohnendes ziel
ich glaube für eine demokratie ist ein
valider sichere wahl
wahlvorgang unerlässlich wenn das in
verruf gekommen und die leute nicht mehr
vertrauen haben dass das vernünftig
abläuft ist das ganz schlimm deren
auswirkungen kann man gar nicht weit
genug denken in der richtung
die sicherheitsbehörden sind nervös und
sie haben gute gründe das vertrauen in
das demokratische system soll
erschüttert werden angriffe durch
hacking und desinformationen werden wohl
auch nach der bundestagswahl nicht
aufhören
[Musik]